this is the smugglers route we're in the
south of Tunisia heading toward the city
of Gafsa near the Algerian border
there's a smuggler on the road ahead of
us one of many we encounter today a
pickup truck loaded with fuel canisters
everyone knows the gas comes from
Algeria or Libya the smugglers operate
in broad daylight and don't turn a
single head since the revolution black
market activity has exploded we meet one
smuggler who asks us to conceal his
identity he went to university but
couldn't find a job he's been in the
business for years even before the
Revolution but in recent months it's
become increasingly easy some duh
yattaman beautiful pilot the police look
the other way this man says they know
the situation they know why we do this
and that we're not stealing from anyone
technically they should arrest me he
says but they think that regardless of
whether they stop us or not they won't
get anything out of it shouldn't do a
new journey my salary's won't get better
either yo honey tied because editor name
is a detergent asada tvz it's indicative
of the situation in Tunisia chaos and
anarchy in the country still considered
the model nation of the Arab Spring
gafsa is the regional capital and the
city that best showcases the
exploitation of the phosphate industry
phosphates are Tunisia's only export
product in their mind in this region a
mind dumped on the outskirts of the city
stands as testimony
the people who live here seen none of
the profits reaped from the ground only
a few have work frustration is
especially high among the youth and not
just since the revolution there were
anti-government protests and strikes
here starting in two thousand eight
that's why some say this is where the
revolution really began even back then
things were dire for the people in Gaza
and nothing has changed this is farhat
he's in his 20s and unemployed just like
all his friends his father gets work
from time to time as a day laborer the
wages provide enough to get by and to
pay for two rooms to live in that's how
it is for everyone here if your rod says
Fiat tells me his financial situation is
very bad there are no opportunities no
future whether you're educated or not in
fact if he had dropped out of school
earlier he might have been able to find
a simple job he says it's not worth it
to invest in education but there's no
work anyway it's not gonna not gonna not
gonna come back and you had my [ __ ] had
to see
but farhat has his music and his friends
from the band they call themselves the
South boys they're the best known
rappers in the region they sing about
Gafsa about unemployment and about the
system that has forsaken them liberal
vista cigna Helmer you will yo wishing
my lab ethnic element l'hospital's you
red diamond diva four ha with autonomous
foolish favela Jeremiah has a filmic
mood yo but hetalia to mimic a terrible
garsuleth doublet a cure for bother with
them we're on it sexiest these young men
have lost faith in the revolution before
then Ali was their enemy now it's the
new leaders in Tunis they don't want any
more promises they just want to voice
their protest through music politicians
their dogs few ret says because a person
created by God wouldn't do any harm to
the country that he himself lives in
would help us youth or Gafsa exists only
for phosphates this young man says they
think only about phosphates the people
don't matter
the phosphate industry is controlled by
state-owned companies unrest and strikes
have stopped work for months offices are
often unoccupied and it's unclear who's
responsible for what
after we try unsuccessfully for weeks to
get permission to film eventually our
contact on site succeeds but it takes
him an entire day
then we're finally on the hot and dusty
desert road to a mine phosphates are
excavated in open pit mines a few years
ago Tunisia was the second largest
phosphate exporter in the world then
came the revolution and things came to a
halt production has resumed now but only
at a fraction of the scale there are
some layers of pure phosphate and others
where the valuable raw material has to
be separated from the soil phosphate is
used in agriculture as a fertilizer and
it's used in the food industry biting
dust out here seals up your nose and
eyes the mining waste is processed
somewhere else it's radioactive and
toxic the work is hard and the
conditions brutal it was mine workers
who took to the streets in 2008 to
demand better living conditions break
time the workers offer us some of their
food spicy sauces salad and home-baked
bread vodka Dori has worked in the mines
for a long time he and his family can
live off the wages but the job is
grueling accidents are common and many
workers get sick and die young municipal
policy on ya little pollution doesn't
just affect us this minor says it
affects the whole region everyone who
lives here yonni there's cancer
everywhere it's alarming what's the city
safer Harry boba
we climb with mourad kedua up onto his
dump truck his job drive unload drive
unload all day long he curses the many
strikes and road blockades that
increasingly bring work to a standstill
his livelihood is at stake it isn't how
he pictured democracy we overcame a
dictatorship but the situation is worse
now he says all sectors are affected the
economy tourism society all because of
the strikes and because of jihadists
jihadists are a constant topic of
discussion extremism is taking a toll on
the country the south is traditionally
socialist but here to extremists have
reportedly made inroads among the young
and discontent
next we meet with Hassan Radel we from
Gafsa he's a member of the assembly
charged with drafting the Constitution
and he's on his way to Tunis he's a
backbencher there gafsa isn't a big
concern for the new Parliament even
though the region is key to the economy
this region has been marginalized for 50
years read always says ever since
Bourguiba and Ben Ali it was excluded
from all development and at the same
time it's the richest region in the
country because of the raw materials a
former postal worker rideau he hasn't
been able to achieve much for the region
he represents like him many hope against
hope that politicians can do something
for them unpaid compensation missing
approvals denied loans the list of
complaints people come to him with is
endless almost all of them are
dissatisfied we accompany her son
wedowee for a portion of his journey
not far from here are the Humvee
mountains where security forces recently
found an Islamic terrorist camp but
according to readily the extremists are
just a passing phenomenon radicalization
is normal after a revolution he says
it'll soon subside what it's our nature
to up on the test you see Brad always
says he thinks the Constitutional
Assembly is working well and that any
claims to the contrary are wrong my
apartment makes this he says the
Assembly members are working hard and he
adds the Constitution is almost finished
the video store when had the store de
job things are tense in Tunis as well
after the murder of opposition
politician chokri belaid in February and
violent confrontations with salafists
but political business continues as
usual here in the parliamentary
cafeteria Hassan Radel we has a quick
conversation before the next session he
used to belong to a socialist party but
it was dissolved
Brad Aoi is one of many here without
much political experience there are taxi
drivers civil servants sales women now
members of parliament just outside the
assembly thousands have gathered for a
demonstration they're members of the
security forces protesting inadequate
equipment and pay in a fight with she
hottest one of their colleagues was
gravely wounded there are protests here
every day against lawmakers inside
against what they're doing or what
they're failing to do there needs to be
a real uprising says this man tell them
they have to stand up why are they glued
to their chairs only God can protect us
from them standing up for democracy
that's still what most Tunisians want
democracy no extremism no terror and
never again a dictatorship our
conclusion the situation is precarious
but the will of the people of Tunisia
remains unbroken